hey everyone welcome the world is
changing the climate is changing farmers
are struggling droughts are more common
floods are more intense it's a right
mess traditional farming methods aren't
enough anymore we need a new approach
climate smart agriculture Farmers need
to adapt they need to find ways to grow
more food with fewer resources they need
to protect their crops from extreme
weather that's where climate smart
agriculture comes in
[Music]
climate smart agriculture or CSA is a
new way of farming that addresses the
challenges posed by climate change it
helps Farmers adapt to climate change by
using Innovative techniques and
Technologies and it helps to reduce
agriculture's impact on the environment
by promoting sustainable practices CSA
has three main goals first increase
productivity this means growing more
food on the same amount of land Farmers
need to grow more food to feed a growing
population which is expected to reach
9.7 billion by
2050 second make farming more resilient
this involves developing crops that can
withstand extreme weather conditions CSA
helps Farms cope with extreme weather
events like droughts and floods ensuring
food Security even in adverse conditions
third reduce agriculture's environmental
impact and this includes minimizing the
use of chemical fertilizers and
pesticides farming contributes to G
greenhouse gas emissions which are a
major driver of climate change CSA aims
to change that by encouraging the use of
renewable energy sources and sustainable
farming practices by adopting CSA
farmers can play a crucial role in
combating climate change while ensuring
food security for future
Generations technology is transforming
farming in unprecedented ways it's a key
part of climate smart agriculture which
aims to increase productivity while
reducing environmental impact let's look
at three game-changing technologies that
are revolutionizing the agricultural
landscape iot drones and AI iot sensors
monitor crops and soil conditions
continuously they provide realtime data
on moisture levels temperature and
nutrient content allowing Farmers to
make informed decisions drones provide a
bird's eye view of farms capturing
detailed images and data from above they
can spot problems early on like pest or
diseases enabling timely interventions
to protect crops AI analyzes data from
sensors and drones processing vast
amounts of information quickly and
accurately it helps Farmers make better
decisions about irrigation fertilization
and Pest Control optimizing resources
and boosting yields by integrating these
Technologies farmers can achieve more
sustainable and efficient farming
practices ensuring food security for the
future technology is great but it's only
part of the solution good old-fashioned
sustainable farming practices are
essential too one key practice is no
till farming it minimizes soil
disturbance which helps retain moisture
and nutrients another is crop rotation
it helps to control pests and diseases
and it improves soil Health cover
cropping is another important practice
it helps to prevent soil erosion and
improve soil
fertility section five success stories
Farmers winning with CSA all over the
world farmers are embracing climate
smart Agriculture and they are seeing
amazing results in India farmers are
using drought resistant seeds and drip
irrigation they're increasing their
yields and saving water in Africa
farmers are using mobile apps to access
weather information and market prices
they're making better decisions and
increasing their
profits section six the future of
farming is now the future of farming is
here and its climate smart new
technologies are emerging all the time
vertical farming allows us to grow food
in urban areas reducing Transportation
costs and Emissions Precision
fermentation uses microbes to create
animal-free proteins reducing the
environmental impact of livestock
farming these Technologies are changing
the game they're making farming more
efficient more sustainable and more
resilient section seven your farm
climate smart getting started
welcome to the journey of transforming
your farm into a climate smart Haven
ready to make your farm climate smart
it's an exciting and rewarding process
that not only benefits the environment
but also enhances your Farm's
productivity and resilience here's how
to get started Begin by understanding
the current state of your farm take
detailed notes and use technology to
track your progress first assess your
Farm's current practices look at your
crop management soil Health water usage
and energy consumption identify areas
where you can improve sustainability
this might include reducing Water waste
enhancing soil fertility or adopting
renewable energy sources second explore
available resources there are many
government programs and nonprofit
organizations that can provide support
they offer valuable information
financial assistance and Technical
expertise to help you implement climate
smart practices third start small
Implement one or two changes at a time
this could be as simple as plan in cover
crops or setting up a more efficient
irrigation system don't try to do
everything at once it's important to
pace yourself and make gradual
improvements reflect on your progress
and adjust your strategies as needed and
remember every step you take towards
climate smart agriculture is a step
towards a more sustainable future
celebrate your successes no matter how
small and stay committed to continuous
Improvement Section 8 conclusion a
hopeful Harvest
climate change is a serious threat but
it's not insurmountable climate smart
agriculture offers hope it's a way to
adapt to a changing climate protect our
planet and feed a growing population
it's time to embrace the future of
farming it's time to embrace climate
smart agriculture if you're enjoying
this content and want to see more don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
turn on notifications you'll be the
first to know when I post new videos and
there's plenty more exciting stuff on
the way want to take your skills to the
next level I highly recommend joining
skillshare via a link below be blessed